ces prémices et voilà je kiffe quand il
est là il est magnifique regardez comme
il est bien coiffée d bien peignés on en
croit d'ailleurs sarah sa responsable
beauté voilà qui est magnifique
également et je sais que soria elle est
folle de philippe lellouche ça veut dire
ainsi elle devait partir sur une île
déserte seul avec un homme pendant 18
ans se serait philippe lellouche lui
parler joë bousquet sur ceux qui bernard
montiel avec une moitié robert ce tuner
robert a vraiment senti vraiment qu'elle
a que ça à [ __ ] des nations au
contraire c'est vraiment une femme
examen médical et j'ai adoré vous
nicolas pernikoff robert julia
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sophie marceau encore sauf celle à la
tunisie dans son village cela se fait
des amis ils veulent pas là là je ne
peux pas aller sur une île déserte avec
des gens ont lâché la d'isabelle vous
moi vous pour voir culture à l'autre je
pourrais pas mal moi je moi j'irai avec
vous mais ce serait rire mais ça c'est
abbas a c'est sûr ça sur gilbert des ac
sera avec fatal et un mytho alors oui
c'est bon basson on attend tous la
réponse que de delphine ondes radio est
vrai qu'on fait ce tournoi pas non plus
raté de l'histoire
bobby avec qui avec scarlett johansson
il va falloir commencer à savoir
prononcer son nom parce que je le
connais pas mais ça
legueulle astrazeneca star les jackson
très bientôt at il dit ah ben moi non
mais je vais faire la même réponse que
gilles moi je partirai que ma femme
la vidéo en vérité les mecs tu là toute
la journée arrête un peu oui mais pas
sur une île mais alors mais sur lui le
mécanisme match mais dans le jardin
c'est une île qui c'est qui va pouvoir
non mais franchement non franchement je
suis pas content oui alors ma dernier le
rigolo mais s'il veut pas partir avec
moi je pense
gaël monfils va se marier mais alors
mais vous dites ça marche pas l'histoire
non non non non ça kane sur l'île
déserte les gars
bel arrêt
on n'est pas là pour pêcher les
écrevisses et vous appris justement non
mais alors et qu'on va lui refaire un
autre collie et non non non non alors
vous médecine wespiser leonardo dicaprio
et si l'epa dispose front games ah ouais
alors parce que quand vous passez de
genton c'est comme si sur la tête de ma
mère alors mais ça c'est super beau
gosse tu peux maintenant je suis pas
d'accord mais alors vos gosses il est
bon et intelligent mais oui c'est oui
mais c'est bien bernardo dicaprio et
alors j'adore leonardo dicaprio
j'adore ya aujourd'hui mais ces deux
mondes différents
comme les autres il a fait le loup de
wall street mais c'est vrai nom lui
c'est laura doigts
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ils appellent ça va vous êtes réveillé
mais c'est un très bien j'avais là bien
sûr qui vient d'être compagne et à
montier isa sabatier va clou alors deux
buts à du public tu te la pètes autsai
msg le verbe est je crois qu'il est
vraiment parti je crois qu'il est
vraiment parti de chez lui à non il est
de retour
regardez-moi sociaux mort avec thé ou
partiriez avec fatou bintou c'est sa
femme bien sûr c'est pas son chauffeur
[Applaudissements]
non mais je rate une fois de viol un
petit peu oui moi bah oui habitude
maintenant oui c'est vrai qu'on a
l'habitude les cherry on est donc c est
toi tu pars avec qui c'est qui va partir
non moi je vous réponds moi je mais j'ai
déjà dit oui c'est vrai avec pareil il
avait préféré nier que vous le croyez
mais non parce que norm coleman
qu'est-ce que vous mentez là mais pas du
tout parce qu'un prix toile isabelle si
je rencontre quelqu'un sur l'île elle
sera sûre et certaine que je suis pas
mais qu'elle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]